[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing beloved hogwarts headmaster
albus dumbledore more specifically i'm
going to be discussing aspects of
dumbledore's character that people who
have only seen the films won't know
that's right if you're a book reader you
probably know all of these at least i
hope so but if you've only watched harry
potter on the silver screen then you're
in for a shock
dumbledore's a main character and a
complex one that so you may be surprised
at just how much of him was left out of
the films let's get into it number 10
his letter to aunt petunia
petunia evans was harry's aunt the
daughter of mr and mrs evans and the
sister of lily evans aside from a few
moments of clarity in the books and
films petunia along with her husband
vernon are primarily portrayed as bad
people they mistreated harry from a very
young age and despised all things
magical but what might surprise you if
you've only seen the films is that
petunia wasn't always so bad
you see petunia's hatred of the magical
world stem from the fact that her sister
was a witch and she wasn't
jealousy was her biggest problem in fact
she even wrote to dumbledore several
times asking if she would be able to
attend hogwarts along with her sister
eventually dumbledore wrote back and had
to politely decline a petunia's request
to attend the school she wasn't a witch
so there was no way that she could ever
go to magical school makes sense 9. jam
dumbledore certainly loves his sweets
this is highlighted in both books and
films sherbet lemons acid pops bertie
bott's every flavor beans these were all
treats that dumbledore enjoyed in fact
dumbledore's office was password
protected the name of his favorite treat
now i know you're dying to know what's
the relevance of jam here well it's
revealed in the books that dumbledore's
favorite jam is raspberry this
information is given to harry so that he
can confirm dumbledore's identity 8. tom
riddle's job application the defense
against the dark arts professor role at
hogwarts is cursed that's why no
professor seems to be able to keep the
role for more than one school year i'm
not sure if you noticed the trend of a
new dander professor in each and every
book film
so what's the deal well it all started
with voldemort or at that time tom
riddle himself interviewing for the
position
who was his interviewer why dumbledore
of course
voldemort wasn't openly evil yet and to
many he was still just a promising young
hogwarts graduate but dumbledore whose
sharpest attack knew that riddle wanted
the role for nefarious reasons
from that day onward riddle voldemort
cursed the role so that no one would
ever be able to teach dada for more than
one year seven he was a hogwarts prefect
like everyone else even the all-powerful
and wise dumbledore once walked through
the halls of hogwarts for the very first
time he was sorted into gryffindor house
and quickly befriended ilfaius doge a
wizard who later joined the order of the
phoenix albus was an incredible student
while he attended the school performing
extremely well on all of his newts and
even receiving the barnabas finkley
prize for exceptional spell casting he
was a top tier student in the deathly
hallows book it's later revealed that
dumbledore was both prefect and head boy
during his time at school no surprises
there
6. his funeral in the films dumbledore
is killed by severus snape during the
battle of the astronomy tower but though
the moment is certainly sad and
impactful there isn't really much
follow-up after dumbledore's death in
the books however dumbledore's death is
heavily highlighted and there's even a
funeral that takes place to honor the
deceased headmaster the funeral was a
grand occasion with a vast number of
attendees including ministry of magic
officials hogwarts students and
professors order of the phoenix members
the landlord of the leaky cauldron the
night bus driver madame malkin and even
some of his enemies the list goes on
dumbledore ends up being buried on the
hogwarts grounds
5. dumbledore's visit to the dursley
home one rather bigger mission from the
films was dumbledore himself paying a
visit to the dursley residents to pick
up harry after inviting himself into
their home and an interesting engagement
he says the following you did not do as
i asked you have never treated harry as
a son he has known nothing but neglect
and often cruelty at your hands the best
that can be said is that he has at least
escaped the appalling damage you
inflicted upon the unfortunate boy
sitting between you ouch
4. death of his sister we know from the
harry potter films that dumbledore's
sister aryana is dead but what's not
properly explained is how she died
more importantly it's not revealed that
dumbledore feels that he himself may
have been the killer the following
passage highlights this
it was the truth i feared you see i
never knew which of us in that last
horrific fight had actually cast the
curse that killed my sister you may call
me cowardly you would be right harry i
dreaded beyond all things the knowledge
that it had been i who brought about her
death not merely through my arrogance
and stupidity but that i actually struck
the blow that snuffed out her life
dumbledore went about his days with the
knowledge that he may have been the one
to kill her which must have been
impossibly hard to deal with
3. his portrait hogwarts headmasters
commonly receive portraits after their
death these portraits are meant to act
as a memoirs of the deceased honoring
their existence mcgonagall once
explained to harry that these portraits
are also supposed to be a support
mechanism for the decisions of the new
headmaster what you didn't see in the
film however was a portrait of good old
dumbledore at one stage when harry ron
and hermione enter the headmaster's
office they see a familiar face staring
back at them
2. voldemort vs dumbledore the jewel
between voldemort and dumbledore inside
of the ministry atrium in the order of
the phoenix is the best jewel in the
entire series
it's two of the most powerful wizards
going head to head and it's impressive
in both the books and the films however
some of the magic the dumbledore uses in
this jewel is completely omitted from
the film and i want to highlight this
magic because it's pretty cool
you see amidst the chaos dumbledore
actually uses his impressive magical
ability to transfigure statues to life
which protect harry and other students i
have nothing more to say to you potter
voldemort did quietly you have irked me
too often for too long avada kadavra
harry had not even opened his mouth to
resist his mind was blank his wand
pointing uselessly at the floor but the
headless golden statue of the wizard in
the fountain had sprung alive leaping
from its plinth to land with a crash on
the floor between harry and voldemort
the spell merely glanced off its chest
as the statue flung at its arms to
protect harry number one memories if you
know dumbledore then you'll know that
he's an affinity for gadgets and magical
artifacts one artifact in particular the
pensive plays a pretty big role in the
story a pensive is of course a magical
object used to review memories but one
thing required to use the pensive are
well memories in the films we see lots
of memories snape's dumbledore's own
when he visits tom riddle slughorn's
interactions with tom riddle etc but
it's never mentioned in the films that
dumbledore also has other memories that
he can review these memories belong to
bob ogden an old ministry employee honky
the house elf and morphin gaunt and
that's it for this video if you like
this type of content then please like
the video and subscribe to the channel
who do you want to see next comment down
below also if you haven't already be
sure to check out my top 5 richest
wizarding families video which i'll link
in the pinned comment until next time
remember differences of habit and
language are nothing at all if our aims
are identical and our hearts are open
you